okay here we have a
session in r in r studio in fact and
we're going to see how we fit logistic
regression models using the the glm
functions in r
so we get the first begin to do is load
the islr
package which has all the data sets
we're going to use
here we use the command require which is
similar to library
i tend to use require
it's sort of
it's more evocative what we're doing
and so
we just click through in our studio
and
the
s marker data sets there and we can
query it so names is useful for seeing
what's on the data frame and summary is
also useful
summary gives you a
simple summary of each of the variables
on on the s market data frame
and we see that there's a number of lags
and there's volume and there's today's
price and there's direction
which we're going to use as a response
and and that is whether the the market
went up or down
since the previous day and we can also
do help on these
data objects
and and get some details of each of the
variables
and so there you see the description so
we're going to use the direction as a
response and see if we can predict it as
a binary response
using logistic regression
let's make a plot of our data so there's
the pairs function
and
we do it it's a little bit crowded in
this plot we told it
to plot the variables in
in
s market
and we told it to use as a color
indicator
they are actually our binary response
and that's a useful way when you've got
a two class
or
a
class variable for seen in the plots
which are
members of each class
and
we see them doesn't seem to be too much
correlation going on here
of course the class variable is derived
from the variable today and so up or
down it seems to make a
division right
and
other than that we don't see much
going on of course with stock market
data you don't expect to see much going
on
because if things were very easy to
predict
people will be making lots of money from
it and they wouldn't be given
lectures on using r
so here we have a call to glm
glm.fit we tell it direction is the
response
and the predictors are going to we're
going to use the lag variables so that
yesterday's
price previous day's price and so on
up to lag five and we'll also use volume
and we tell it to use family equals
binomial and so that tells glm to fit a
logistic regression model instead of one
of the many other models that can be fit
with glm okay so we execute that fit
and
oops
i've skipped a line here so there we go
and
there it's done it's two lines there and
then we do a summary
and the summary
tells you some things about the fit
and in this case
it's giving you p-values on each of the
coefficients the estimated coefficients
they're standard errors the z-score and
the p-value
and it seems like none of the
coefficients are significant here
again not a big surprise for these kinds
of data
it doesn't necessarily mean it won't
make a
be able to make
any kind of reasonable predictions it
just means that possibly these variables
are very correlated actually the plot
doesn't suggest that
anyway none are significant
and it gives the null deviance which is
the deviance just for the mean so that's
the log likelihood if you just use the
mean model and then the deviance for the
model with all the predictors in that's
the residual deviance
and there was a very modest change in
deviance it looks like four units
on um
on
how many degrees of freedom we've got
six degrees of freedom difference in in
degrees of freedom there
okay
so we can make predictions
from the the fitted model
and so we assigned to glm.probs the
predict
of glm.fit and we tell it type equals
response so this will make predictions
on the training data that we use to fit
the model
and it gives you a
vector of fitted probabilities we can
look at the first five
and we see they they're very close to
fifty percent
which is again not too surprising we
don't expect to get strong predictions
in this case
so this is a prediction of whether
the the mark is going to be up or down
based on the
the lags and the other predictors
we can
turn
we can turn those probabilities into
classifications by thresholding at 0.5
and so we do that by using the if else
command so if else takes a vector in
this case glm.probs
in fact a vector of logical so glm.prob
is bigger than 0.5 so that'll be
a vector of trues and falses
and then if else says that element by
element if if it's
if it's true you're going to call it up
otherwise you're going to call it down
and and so that does that for us
and now we're going to look at
our performance and here it's convenient
to actually attach the data frame market
so that the variables are available by
name
which we do and now we can make a table
of glm.pred which is our
ups and downs
from our prediction
against the true direction so we do that
and
we get a table and we see there's lots
of elements on the off diagonal element
on the off diagonals on the diagonals is
where we do
correct classification
and on the off diagonals is where we
make mistakes
and we see there's quite a lot of those
and we can actually get our mean
[Music]
classification performance so that's the
cases where glm.print is equal to the
direction and we just take the mean of
those so it'll give you a proportion in
this case 0.52
so on the training data
we get we
do slightly better than chance well
we may have overfit on the training data
so what we're going to do now is divide
our data up into a training and test set
so what we'll do is
we'll make a
vector of logicals
and what it is is
train is equal to year less than 2005.
for all those observations for which
year is less than 2005 we'll get a true
otherwise we'll get a false
and now we refit our glm.
fit
except we say subset equals train and so
it will use only those observations for
which train is true so now that means we
fit just to the data
in
in years less than 2005
and now when we come to predict
we're going to predict on the
the remaining data which is years 2005
or greater
and
so we use a predict function again
and for the new data we give it s market
but indexed by not trained so that's
going to be
not trained is
it's going to be
true if if year is 2005 or more
and we tell a type equals response so we
actually want to predict
the the probabilities in this case
and again we make this if else if
make this up down variable
and let's make a subset
a new variable direction.2005
again for the test data which is
the response variable direction
which is just for the test dates in
other words not train so we call that
direction.2005
and now we make a table so now this is
on test data there's a smaller subset of
the data is test
and we compute our mean again and it's
0.48 so now we've actually done
gets slightly less than 50 percent
so
it's
we'd be doing worse than the
the null rate which is 50
so
what are we going to do well we might
for this we might be overfitting and
that's why we're doing worse on the on
the on the test data
so now we're going to fit a smaller
model
so
we're going to just use lag 1 and lag 2
and leave out all the other variables
and so
here we do that the rest of the calls
the same
and then we run through our commands
again
we compute our table
and here we get an error rate of of 55
a correct classification of just about
56
which is not too bad at all
and
so
using the smaller model appears to have
done better here and if we do a summary
of that guy
let's see if anything became significant
by using the smaller model
that it gave us better predictions
and of course that's what happens when
you try and do commands on the type on
the fly at least for me you make
spelling mistakes
well nothing became significant but at
least the prediction of performance
appeared to have improved
so that's for the logistic regression
models in r using the glm function and
family equals binomial